I think about leaving a legacy like Dave
always talks about every generation
should get better if she gets smarter
she gets stronger and when we know when
my kids have kids I want them to look
back and be like hey you know let me
tell you what my dad or my granddad did
to get his family free you know he went
to where he was a police officer
he worked crazy insane hours was always
gone and I want them to be proud and be
like hey this guy he took responsibility
for his life and that's a generation of
curse that we can say stops here we of
course will let them know that so that
they know hey you don't need to do that
you don't have to go there being the
police officer I come across a lot of
people that are victims and I decided
that I didn't want to be a victim cuz I
seen how victims can be you know they're
sometimes they're downtrodden they're
beat down they feel like they have no
control you know we took responsibility
for the credit cards the piled up bills
you know the stress the depression and
in turn you know it's actually made me a
better police officer too because I go
to a lot of domestic calls where you
have couples that are arguing I can tell
them hey I know where you I know how you
feel I know we've been so I can kind of
get down with them and kind of recognize
with them in their issue
my name is Dexter Pitts and we live in
Louisville Kentucky
and I'm a police officer and my name is
Christina Pitts and I am a program
manager for an agency that provides
residential supports for people with
intellectual and developmental
disabilities
we've known each other since the seventh
grade but we actually reconnected a few
years ago through Facebook we just
became friends started driving down to
see your Bowling Green and going to
church with her next you know we were
married and have two kids and she's
still with me so money is so
uncomfortable to talk about even between
people that are married I mean the
number one cause of divorce in America
is money problems and we wanted to make
sure that wasn't gonna be an issue you
know in the back of my mind like we need
to save money but I'm like we have joint
accounts we have enough money you know I
can go out and buy and spin but really
it was not the best place for us but to
be totally honest like even like from
the way I grew up we just made enough we
were comfortable where we were but
that's kind of just how how it was so
that's where the stress came definitely
I saw it in my husband where he was like
I have enough money but we just have
enough my mind I was okay you know but
when we got married and things got her
know there were a little bit tighter
with the mortgage in her note when we
threw in her bills and my bills together
it was real tight and it just you know
it got really uncomfortable
[Music]
we got married in August and I called
him in this one November and said hey
we're pregnant she kept telling me that
she was pregnant and I'm just thinking
man I'm not ready yet this is not
supposed to happen yet
and the next thing though I just
remember right around my police car
listening in the Dave Ramsey on the
radio and then I told her I was like I
think I'm gonna get his class we're
gonna do the Financial Peace University
and from then it ought to be just I dove
in we immediately started making cuts
and I started working extra jobs and I
told her I think it's time we sell the
house to her growing up the way she grew
up in a very you know moderate family
she never had really lived in a house
always apartments but she did not want
to let go of this big house and all this
space she had and she saw the vision
that I had as she understood it like a
good wife she actually she followed me
and believed me in my vision but to be
honest again I was the one dragging my
feet like I did not want to do this it
was uncomfortable because that means
giving up what I have dreamed about so
long of having a house so I guess he was
mostly the saver and I was a spinner he
wanted to just cut off everything
next you know we sold the house and we
moved into a tiny two-bedroom
two-bathroom apartment maybe 800 square
feet it was on the third floor and it
was a long three years we stayed there
we saved a lot of money but we also paid
off most of our debt in that time I said
I was working then maybe close to 100
100 plus hours a week I would come in
and I would go get a shower lay down for
a little bit and go back off the door
and go back to work and every day I
would just wake up and look at my wife
and look at our little newborn daughter
and I'd be like you know I got to do
this and we're free yeah and that's the
best part I don't have to work like I
used to work it feels wonderful now he
has a choice because of course you have
working families who are always working
trying to just make ends meet but now
that we have our bills paid our children
are able to see us more to enjoy those
special times within that our children
don't feel that stress our kids they get
to see us you know do our budget we put
all our money into the envelope system
use the every dollar app you know and
they know what's going on they might not
get a true understanding but they're
seeing it in action and the more they
watch it the more they understand when
they get older and they're gonna be able
to help him in it we paid off 265
thousand dollars with the debt and about
forty five months we both made a
decision together as a family
to stick with it because it was
difficult it's not easy but what's ever
worth anything if you don't put that
much work into it so this is just
encouragement that whatever that amount
is it's nothing brighter than what God
can help you make it through and I think
it also has widen our scope because we
were looking through a lens
small and we weren't able to see what
all we could affect so now that is widen
that we're able to see how many people
we can bless how many lives we can touch
so now we can look back and say it's
over and we have been able to reach and
overcome that mountain in our lives to
be able to focus on what's true which is
helping and serving others and that's
what FPU and being free is all about
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]